so for a guy that built entourage on you
know which by the way some may call it
the greatest show of all time to me it's
a top five of mine I think it's just
insane if you when you ask some people
that are newer guy younger guy they're
in their 20s like have you seen a what's
Entourage I'm like dude you missed out I
slapped them right in the face what life
it's not like you don't know what life
is boy I watch them but but you do this
and it becomes a phenomenon it becomes a
uh everyone's talking about it at work
the next day everyone's talking about it
at the peak of insanity tell us a crazy
insane story when Entourage was peaking
how the the in the community how
Hollywood was looking at it tell us tell
us some crazy stories about the whole
Entourage movement I mean I'm trying to
think what crazy stories I have but you
know I I always even though I wrote that
show I was always kind of like a head
down guy and and I'm not kind of living
in anything like that Entourage Life In
fact when when Mark brought it to me
because my Mark said I wanted to show
about me and my friends like and I'm
like a bunch of hanger ons who hang out
with a movie star I'm like it's just not
my speed and and and you know he he said
think about it and I went home and
thought about how to make these guys
like a family and and that's you know
any any successful show that's
essentially what they are but I mean
it's you know it's not an insane story
but when my brother my brother my
Harvard Law brother who works at Staten
Arps and is Mr Conservative and like I
don't think ever thought like I was even
mildly amusing to him when like when the
hug it out thing happens which honestly
it was I mean I've written far better
lines than that and had no expectation
of this being a thing but when my
brother told me like his whole office in
scat and Arps New York all these Harvard
guys that you know like I I could never
even visit Harvard I was too stupid to
do that so when I hear that they were
talking about it and then when the
athletes would call LeBron James and Tom
Brady like we want to be on the show
that's crazy um it was it was really
wild Phil Mickelson I mean you know I
wrote this line or maybe Brian Birds
wrote this live whatever but he's
melting down like Ari says he's melting
down like like Mickelson at Wingfoot
which was like his famous U.S open
meltdown and then I see him and I'm like
hey Doug Ellen Entourage and he looks at
me he goes you know I'm sitting in bed
with my wife mine in my own business
watching my favorite show
and this comes on you know and uh
come on the show and he still came on so
it was a very it was a very cool wild
ride in the town really embraced the
show which you know speaking of cancer
culture when it started to turn then all
of a sudden the show was racist
homophobic and this I'm like okay well
it was Obama's favorite show you know
the New York Times but it is the best
show you know and and it's weird to see
how I don't think the world has shifted
as much as as you just said it really
hasn't shifted but there's just a lot of
loud voices that are getting a lot of
air and a lot of attention and a lot of
power could you do Entourage today and
get away with it well you know would you
be having to explain yourself every day
for an episode look I I have a new show
that I'm doing now that I believe will
will be speak to society in 2022 the way
that did in 2003. the reality is the
real Ari could never speak the way he
did in an office then so I would never
write that so when people write things
which it's also funny with comedy or you
know some people don't fight it funny
but with comedy you get this thing like
you can't say that you can but The
Sopranos like Tony Soprano can you know
Murder his his son's you know best
friend's father or beat him up or
threaten him whatever and that's that's
okay because it's somehow more artistic
but
um I wouldn't write things that that
don't exist just like you wouldn't write
a show in 2022 where people you know
cars don't exist I mean things evolve
things change society's changed in what
I think hopefully what I did well and
why it captured the culture is is I
understood what Hollywood was like in
2003 and by the way it was mild compared
to reality you know and but it still did
speak of some reality and and some real
world issues Adrian Greener I mean out
of all the guys there Kevin's been
acting since he was six years old he's
been in Hollywood for a long time right
you know you can and I'm saying Connell
you can go through everybody Kevin
Dillon's been asking yeah
Jeremy piven's been acting for 40
freaking years at this point incredible
actor but but what did age where did you
guys find him so Adrian was uh pull up
the picture for some people that don't
know he's from Entourage go for it
Adrian is for the people that don't know
who he is I I want to spit in your face
entourage is wake up so but but Adrian
Adrian Steve Levinson who was a better
picture Tyler that's him there you go
that's a good picture he gets the worst
picture of the guy go ahead and Chase in
the house Vince so Steve Levinson who I
went to Tulane with and as it was a good
friend and was Mark's manager
um he represented Adrian and Adrian when
we were casting his I I cannot tell you
how hard it is to cast a movie star who
is not a movie star this is literally
one of the hardest things on the planet
and Adrian who is a great actor who
actually Woody Allen cast as a movie
star I think you know opposite Leo and
um I forgot what that movie was called
one of his is less least successful
movies but Adrian would be in this
office every day while we were pulling
our hair out trying to pull it out and
then Steve one day was like you know I
got the guy I'm like who's the guy and
and he's like him and agent had this
beard like we did this episode where he
goes to Mexico and yeah he had this
beard he would always wear a hoodie and
you know and and I'm I'm not a
homophobic guy at all but I don't like
stare at handsome men and go whatever
I'm like the guy in the corner with like
the hoodie and the beard you know and
he's like yeah that's the guy that guy
cleans up nicely yeah but even when he
didn't clean up we just put him on tape
and uh one of our
um one of our assistants did a genius
thing back in 2003 he took Connolly's
audition and he took Adrian's audition
and put him together Connolly's Kyle is
a handsome guy you know but uh when we
put him together Adrian just he
instantaneously felt like a movie star
you know and um you know some people
like to say he wasn't great anyway let
me tell you something there's very few
people on the planet who could have
pulled off that role and really had this
presence in the show that that just made
you feel like I want to be around this
guy I want to be friends with this guy
and I want to be in his orbit but um so
we we were lucky because we saw every
single person in town and it was tricky
and when I started I wanted I wanted a
Wahlberg which is even harder because
you know as you look around in the
movies there's very few guys like Mark
you know so speaking of Ari Gold was
Jeremy Piven born to play that role like
did you even look elsewhere so I my
agent at CA was a guy named Jeff Jacobs
who I went to Camp with 30 years ago he
was my agent
Jeremy who I'd never met in my life I
loved and from Larry Sanders
specifically so in the first outline
that Harry Shandling is that back in the
day this is the Larry [ __ ] show probably
this is legitimately top five sitcoms
ever made I mean it's genius and uh you
know Bob Odenkirk was the inspiration
for the agent Better Call Saul he was
the agent on Larry Sanders and when I
was thinking of an agent he was kind of
my inspiration but then I saw Jeremy and
he kind of looked like a little bit like
my agent and I so in my first thing I
said Jeremy Piven playing Jeff Jacobs
you know and then what happened was we
went into the pitch meeting at HBO I had
never heard of Ari Emmanuel I had never
met him nothing but he represented Mark
and Steve Levinson so I was with Jeff
Jacobs and you know they were with Ari
and we walked into the room and I've
told this before but you know I'm
sitting there with 35 pages of like
stories and material for this show and
we walk in and our Mario manual before
anyone says a word goes it's a show
about Mark and his friends this guy is
going to write it if it sucks we're
gonna fire him and someone else is going
to rewrite it wow okay says it to your
face oh yeah yeah in the meeting and
then uh so that was pretty much the end
of the meeting I didn't even really have
to speak and uh the first thing I said
to to Steve Levinson after we walked out
I go he's Piven plays him this is the
guy and we then got in the car and Ari
calls I I honestly did not say a word I
had a 15-minute pitch ready to say I
don't think I said a word all right goes
done they bought it I said do they want
to like read any of my writing samples
and he goes I just said they bought it
would you like them to unbuy it so so
instantaneously I knew I had a character
that would pop and then I I meet Jeremy
he's gotten into shape and he actually
kind of now looks like Ari it was so
bizarre
um can you pull up a picture of uh
but uh you know um so then we had I had
to convince Jeremy to do the show by the
way so what do you mean convince him he
didn't well he didn't know who I was he
didn't know who any of the other actors
were and we weren't paying a lot it was
a very low budget thing when we started
so uh we met and we convinced him to do
it and it was great and um you know
there was no other options he'll click
on that picture right in the middle
between uh right in the middle between
no no in the middle right there that's
the picture
yeah because that's who he's playing
yeah it's it's wild he's uh he's he's a
great actor though he started doing
stand-up right before the pandemic I
started seeing him at the Laugh Factory
I moved here from L.A he's saying Piven
being pivot and then he all I got off
stage and he was like dude like holy
[ __ ] and like we kind of you know we're
both handsome whatever all right so so
but he was he was just awesome and like
uh he was like Hey I'm gonna go perform
in Utah one of the uh comedy clubs he's
like I was like I'm gonna go see my
sister she's in the Air Force like dude
coming open for me and feature he's in
the back smoking cigars he's he's he's
he's not cool he saw you do a podcast
with how you living J Piven his podcast
I'm gonna Circle back to kind of what we
brought up initially and I no doubt I
mean is he the only one who actually won
a an Emmy or something from he's uh as
far as actors he's the only one yeah and
Dylan were both not okay but I mean
obviously he crushed three in a row yeah
which is ridiculous
um
but you brought up a point earlier like
whoa what what are would he be canceled
these days who knows but Sopranos it's
crazy speaking of First Amendment
Sopranos and you can even go down the
depth chart of like whatever you know
murders or Grand Theft Auto you could
full-on murder someone gun to the Head
yeah just blood plus that's fine yeah
but God forbid you call someone a nasty
name oh you'll get it you could do that
on The Sopranos too yeah you can call
them whatever you want so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]